joga desde muito tempo
os meus avós que eram pessoas muito
sábias na minha comunidade
eles contavam para nós quem eram as
pessoas que viviam aqui antes dos outros
chegar e por incrível que pareça no
início não haviam pessoas
houveram dois gênios que viviam no meio
da terra e que saíram de uma montanha e
esses dois gémeos criaram tudo que há o
nome deles é calé e cairo também criou
tudo que é cumprido e é arriscado
a cobra o tigre araucária e cairo criou
tudo que é manchado e é redondo a onça
a tartaruga e depois
kamei casou os seus filhos com as filhas
de cairu e cairo caso as suas filhas com
os filhos de câmara desta união nasceram
os kaingang que é o meu povo o povo
indígena caingangue ele é dual ele é
complementar para nós não pode existir
dia se não existe noite pra nós existe
água
existe sol porque existe lua existe
masculino porque existe feminino dessa
dualidade vive o meu povo e nós a partir
do momento que nascemos
precisamos estar conectados com a
espiritualidade
nós precisamos estar conectados com os
espíritos dos nossos ancestrais e os
espíritos dos nossos ancestrais estão no
nosso território do nosso território que
é a nossa casa
neles estão os espíritos das águas os
espíritos da floresta os espíritos os
nossos que já se foram e que aguardam
por nós que um dia iremos eu sou
josiléia da nisa a em bangui da terra
indígena de serrinha no rio grande do
sul
e eu sou mulher pra nós caingangue é
importante quando as mulheres falam
porque as mulheres têm uma conexão com
esse mundo que não é terreno que é o
outro mundo
o meu povo viveu desde tempos imemoriais
em um território que vinha desde o sul
de são paulo até o rio grande do sul
e nesse território o meu povo vivia em
harmonia com o ambiente
em 1900 1860
o governo brasileiro implementou um
projeto de tirar os índios do mato
então naquela época século 19
a intenção era tirar os índios do mato e
colocar eles em pequenos aldeamentos
deixar os indígenas ilhados depois logo
no início do do outro século
século 19
os colonos que viviam na colônia velha
do estado do rio grande do sul
eles passaram a acessar os aldeamentos
nos quais os indígenas tinham sido
confinados e lá começou a acontecer um
esbulho territorial a venda das terras
indígenas dos tais aldeamentos para
esses outros povos que ali chegavam o
governo tirava de um e vem dia para os
outros a minha terra antes de chita de
se chamar serrinha se chamava focavam
elad focava os meus ancestrais foram
retirados foram retirados violentamente
do território
os últimos que restaram em 1960 quando
se deu a extinção total da minha terra
foram levados em cima de caminhões
amarrados
muitos morreram de tristeza e quando
eles chegaram nesses outros lugares
nesses outros aldeamentos em que todas
as pessoas deveriam ficar em que todos
os indígenas da região sul do brasil
ficavam independente deles e guarani
kaingang e xokleng xetá porque nós somos
305 povos no brasil nós não somos apenas
um ou dois é 305 que continua
sobrevivendo bom quando eles chegavam
nesses aldeamentos muitos não queriam
ficar lhe fugiam
na época dos das pessoas que então
cuidavam de salvamentos que era o
serviço de proteção ao índio que não
protegia ninguém e eles fugiram e
retornavam para ser piores em lavouras
para ser empregados em lavouras dos
colonos que estavam na terra deles então
eles voltavam para o seu lugar de origem
mesmo que fossem
se as condições mesmo que fosse pra
morar em qualquer lugar em qualquer
cantinho pra poder tá ali pra poder
estar conectado com o seu espaço bom
nessa conexão que a gente vê e nessa
conexão histórica que os povos indígenas
têm com o seu lugar
a gente também vem tendo um olhar para
as pessoas não indígenas e essas pessoas
não indígenas que também fazem esse
retorno que também estão buscando se
reconecta com o espaço ea gente vê que
nós temos muitas coisas em comum
quantos de vocês aqui nesse auditório
fazem a opção por comer alimentos
orgânicos
quantos de vocês têm tido a vontade de
ter mais tempo para a vida de ter mais
tempo para viver
quantos de vocês fazem uso da medicina
alternativa da queima de ervas
quantos de vocês meditam olhando só
nasceu o sol se pôr
isso é uma sabedoria ancestral
isso é uma conexão do que a gente é com
a vida com o cosmos que é muito maior do
que isso que a gente tem aqui é muito
maior do que é sair em que a gente vive
nós povos indígenas estamos vendo isso
em vocês reconhecendo isso em vocês e
sim nós temos uma conexão muito forte aí
continuando nós fomos expulsos do nosso
território em serrinha e aí ficamos
desconectados da nossa terra tradicional
os nossos espíritos antigos ficaram lá e
depois da constituição de 88 que
assegura aos povos indígenas o direito
ao seu território
o direito a viver
de acordo de acordo com seus usos
costumes e tradições
nós iniciamos em 1992 um retorno nós
montamos acampamento em dois lugares na
terra indígena serrinha e foi um tempo
bem difícil um tempo em que a sabedoria
das mulheres foi essencial para que as
nossas lideranças tivessem paciência e
fé para negociar tanto com os colonos
quanto com o judiciário
em 1997 o judiciário nos deu parecer
favorável e remarcou nosso território
então nós estávamos voltando para um
lugar que era nosso pra um lugar aonde
os nossos mais velhos tinham nascido e
aonde os nossos mais velhos e mais
antigos estavam enterrados e aonde o
espírito deles continuava lógico foi um
tempo de muita alegria e nós ficamos
muito contentes por estar voltando por
um lugar que era nosso mas infelizmente
nós recebemos uma terra que estava nua
uma terra sem mata de araucária uma
terra onde alguns rios tinham secado e
uma terra com grande parte dela alagada
por uma barragem de usina hidrelétrica
que a barragem do rio passo fundo
nós recebemos um território muito
diferente daquele de onde tinham sido
expulsos
isso nos deixou muito triste mas nós
tínhamos uma alegria porque aquela terra
tinha ficado muito tempo vazia sem um
pedaço dela e esse pedaço tinha voltado
e juntos nós vamos reconstruir tudo
aquilo então desde 1997
nós caingangue de serrinha estamos
mantendo aquele território com árvores
nativas replantando reconstruindo porque
é isso
a gente precisa quando tem uma ferida
cuidar dela para aquelas ari e é isso
que nós temos feito na nossa terra
os nossos mais velhos diziam e eu ouvi
de alguns dos meus avós das minhas avós
que eles estavam agora plenos pra fazer
a passagem ali pra encantar ali e nós
temos também a obrigação de encantar lá
e fazer essa conexão com os nossos em
alegrete que são os nossos espíritos
advogar é e a vaguear que hoje a vaguear
aparece sozinha nessa fotografia advogar
é quando estava lá dizia agora eu posso
ir e a vaguear dizia para ela quando
você for me espera lá porque eu também
vou com tiago
então é isso essa conexão que nós temos
com a nossa espiritualidade com o nosso
território que faz nos seus povos
indígenas que fazem os cerca em bangui
a minha casa é todo meu território e eu
me realizo m constituam ali as lutas não
têm sido fáceis as lutas têm sido
travadas principalmente com o governo as
lutas têm sido travadas com o poder
legislativo judiciário e aí eu quero
dizer pra vocês que sim a presença
feminina é essencial pra gente fazer
mediação de conflito
a gente pode perceber que os povos
indígenas
eles têm carregado um fardo que é dizer
nós precisamos proteger a nossa
biodiversidade
nós precisamos proteger o nosso meio
ambiente nós precisamos proteger os
nossos mananciais de água e aqui vocês
podem ver nessa imagem que é do parque
indígena do xingu
vocês
podem ver ela não mente a imagem não
mente
o parque indígena do xingu está ali com
árvores de pé a fronteira com ele está
toda devastada ea biodiversidade é
necessária pra mim é necessária pra
vocês é necessária para os meus filhos
mas é necessário para os filhos de vocês
também é necessária para todos nós
então nós precisamos nos comprometer em
manter a mata em pé e não produzir tanta
soja e não criar tanto boi
nós precisamos nos comprometer a ter
futuras gerações
e pra isso nós temos criados várias
redes redes de apoio redes de apoio
entre as mulheres entre os homens entre
as crianças indígenas para promover a
demarcação das nossas terras para
promover a demarcação do território
tradicional e sagrado pra nós
não é todo o território brasileiro
nós estamos pedindo apenas as pequenas
parcelas de terra onde a gente tem essa
ligação com a nossa ancestralidade por
isso que não pode ser qualquer
território tem que ser aquele território
em que os nossos estão ali tão bem para
que a gente se torne único e completo e
essas mulheres têm feito essas redes de
luta pela demarcação e temos enfrentado
um outro grande desafio e um outro
grande poder que a mídia a mídia aberta
fala contra os povos indígenas
a mídia aberta sufoca a nossa voz à
mídia aberta conta mentiras sobre os
povos indígenas
então a luta não é contra alguém que é
do nosso tamanho a luta contra alguém
que muito maior do que nós mas nós
sobrevivemos 517 anos
vamos sobreviver ainda mais então o
convite que eu quero fazer pra vocês
é porque vocês pensem sobre os povos
indígenas
pensem sobre a nossa necessidade de
reparação histórica para com os povos
indígenas e nos apóie na nossa luta nos
apoiem na nossa causa apóio a demarcação
dos nossos territórios
muito obrigado